Welcome.
Thank you.
It's a pleasure to be here.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
so Dr Calvin,
that's quite the,
that's quite the resume you have there.
I'm so tell us a little bit more about your work at CSU Fullerton.
So my primary job is really threefold.
Number one,
I teach classes and nutrition performance,
strength conditioning.
Uh,
we of course our laboratories.
So in the Center for sport performance,
we've got about seven different laboratories,
a bomb mechanics,
exercise physiology,
sports psychology,
um,
human performance and motor control,
motor learning.
And so really our job is to produce research that improves the human condition.
We tend to focus on performance and sport performance.
But really as the talk probably evolves here,
you'll probably start to understand how I think that is a little bit more wide
ranging than some people understand.
So if you in spruce sport performance,
it's also a very good microcosm for understanding what improves that general
human condition.
So with that being said,
the third tier really of my job is to disseminate that information that we've
learned in a lot of our laboratories,
in our studies,
to the people that use it.
Whether that be the professional athletes see the UFC fighters or whether that
be you folks at home.
That's also why I do the podcast and why I'm here today and why I wrote the
book.
Uh,
and if you notice the tone,
that book,
it's written for the general public.
It's not written like I with my scientific papers and,
and that's because we're trying to take the things we learned and on laboratory
and put it into practice with the people that are gonna use it and benefit from
it.
Got It.
And so how did you go from,
you know,
leading a lab to working with Olympians and professional MMA fighters?
Well,
that's really the same thing for me.
Um,
they tend to be the participants and subjects in my studies because I'm trying
to learn how muscle functions at the high level is specifically what we do in
our lab is we learn what regulates how muscle grows,
shrinks,
dies and repairs.
And it's important to understand that from the disease prevention treatment
model.
But it's also important to understand the other side of the equation,
which is let's look at the athletes who are the best in the world because now we
understand what we're trying to get to.
And so there's a pretty natural crossover there between these are the people I'm
trying to study,
um,
learning information about them.
Well then let's take the information I know and give it back to them and see if
we could actually change performance.
And so it's really circular works really well that way I get something out of
it,
they get something out of it.
So it was a natural blend.
So let's for a second,
assume that I'm a professional MMA fighter,
which is having a likely cause terrible vision,
tore my meniscus and no neck tattoos.
And you work at Google and now we're at Google?
Probably not.
Yeah,
probably not.
It's probably not a future career move,
but let's for a second as soon that.
So would you work what I only work with you or would you be like part of a crew
of a team?
My role whenever I'm working with an athlete or my mom or anybody else is to do
whatever I need to do to improve that person or to get them.
And if that means you need to work with me directly and only me,
that's fine.
If you need me to be the 43rd person on your team,
that's absolutely fine.
My goal is not to have anyone ever do my system.
I don't have a system.
My goal is to figure out what your problem is and fix it.
The easy example here,
and I'm gonna show you how bad I understand programming,
but this works very easy.
If you had a problem with the some software that wasn't working appropriately
you,
you can't just send the same piece of code to fix everything.
It's easier to just look at the current code,
fix the one problem,
and then go back.
That's all I'm trying to do.
And we have a major fallacy of assuming everyone has that same problem.
So the answer of your question is,
I'm trying to find whatever role I can to help the person through their problem
or to improve them.
If they don't have a problem.
And so I've played every role you can imagine.
Some of the athletes I work with,
I'm pretty high to that at the top and I'm determining what's going on.
Some of them it's very low level stuff.
Uh,
I'm always trying to encourage interaction with all their coaches,
their physicians,
their staff members,
their agents,
whatever I can to help them fix the problem or improve what they're trying to
improve.
That's my circular goal.
It's about them,
not me.
God,
I suppose like having that approach makes it so that working with so many smart
folks,
like they're not stepping on one another's toes cause you're there for the
individual now for yourself.
That that's probably my single biggest piece of advice when working with an
athlete.
They have to understand that because they will see right through that as well.
A lot of people want to work with professional athletes or any high level
functioning person.
It doesn't matter if the professional athlete,
they want to work with that person so that they can level up,
right.
I want this person to succeed so that they can go around and tell the media that
I got better because of Andy.
Right.
And an athlete will see right through that.
And so you have to actually have that altruistic nature were saying,
I'm just trying to help this person because I want to help that person.
If you do it because you want to level up or get fame or fortune from it,
it's not going to work.
So my approach is that way because I'm really genuinely trying to help them.
Most of the athletes that I've worked with have never mentioned me on their
Twitter feed.
They've never posted about me.
And that's fine.
That's not what I do at occasionally.
If they do it,
that's great.
But the point is to help them get better.
Um,
and in a job like mine,
working directly with the athletes is not actually part of my job.
I have laboratories to run your heard of all the things I'm doing.
I could classes to teach of other service to do.
I'm on national boards and a scientific advisory panels and things like that.
So when I work with them that that's a hobby for the most part that goes in that
category in my brain anyways in terms of my workflow.
And so I treat it like that,
which means I'm willing to do this from the altruistic perspective of it gives
me joy,
joy,
joy.
Uh,
I enjoy it and I like to help people.
So if I think I can offer somebody some help,
I will,
but I'm not doing it for me cause I got,
I got names everywhere.
I got books,
I got titles,
I got awards,
like lab.
Last thing I need is the last thing I'm interested in.
Yeah.
Something that really started about your work and I mentioned this to you before
we walked in,
was that it's both really refreshing but also really frustrating because I'm
like,
am
I Quito?
Duane?
How'd you Kiddo?
Like,
which side is the best for me?
And I think,
um,
you know,
there's,
there's this idea that it's a one size fits all mentality for both fitness and
nutrition.
And I was right.
If you could speak a little bit on Kinda like the nuance and kind of the way you
would approach let's say four minute diet for uh,
the high performing an Olympian.
I think the best way I can set this whole story up is a few years ago my
students walked into my classroom on the last day before the final and told me
that they weren't going to take the final that they just handed and they pulled
out from their bag a big bag of diapers and they said,
this is our answer for every question.
Because the answer is always,
it just depends.
Right?
That's,
that's pretty much time to lay down on the job there.
I know.
Yeah,
give it a second.
But,
but that's what you're referring to in terms of frustrating because that is
always the answer.
Physiology is so complex.
And the reason,
even if you had two or 200 people that had the same quote unquote problem,
it may not have the same reason why the problems there.
And so if you give them the same treatment,
it may or may not be effective.
And so I never give people blanket statements.
I will use any tool to fix a job and oftentimes you have innumerable tools that
could fix it and you have to go to your next level of thinking and logic to
figure out which one do I choose because a thousand of them could.
I mean example up here,
I've got two different water bottles up here,
but not identical.
And if my problem was hydration,
there's pros and cons to both approaches here,
right?
And so I'm not trying to just say,
all right,
everyone drink this because it's better.
Everyone drink this,
don't drink this because it's worse.
I want to look through every piece of evidence,
what all possible could be going on here,
what all sponsorable going on here and understand the pros and cons of
implementing that and for my solution.
And that's always what's going through my brain there.
We'll get to this,
I'm sure in a second,
but there's no free passes in physiology.
Everything does something and so you have to consider both the potential help
and the potential consequence of anything you implement,
whether that's food or they're a supplement.
Whether it's a sleep thing,
it's technology of course this is what the book is about.
There are pros and cons to everything.
Everything has an effect.
And now when you start putting that into a system like physiology that is so
complex,
you have to understand when you turn a switch,
it doesn't go on and off.
It does a bunch of different things in physiology.
So the game board is constantly moving.
When you adjust one piece,
it doesn't just do one thing,
it adjust a thousand other things,
millions of other things really.
And so you have to factor all that stuff in.
And at the end of the day you're guessing at anyone that says anything different
in,
in mechanical biology or,
or perhaps the software stuff.
You have a very,
math is a very clear,
you do this,
it turns into that.
Physiology does not work like that.
It is way too complex.
It's biology,
it's two moving,
right?
Um,
the understanding or,
or clarity of truth in biological or medicine is really,
really difficult to get to.
And so you have to have that humility when you,
when you treat people,
when you work with athletes,
understanding I think this how it's going to work based on my experience and the
evidence and everything else had been through.
But at the end of the day,
you don't know.
You're just guessing.
So what would be an example of like up at that trade off of like,
let's say the example I've heard you use before it was like vitamin C.
Yeah.
Yes.
So can you share a little bit about that?
The counterbalance of,
you know,
taken in vitamin C as a supplement?
Well,
I mean,
I'll,
I'll use,
I'll make an easier one.
Vitamins and minerals are the easy go to because if you just take vitamin C
prophylactically,
so he just took it all day.
Every that's consequences that it has extreme toxicity.
The idea here is called a whore,
which means there's,
there's a toxicity curve to everything.
And Water,
I'll give you,
I'll go to here because then even easier example,
which sets the point better.
How many of you would be willing to stop drinking water the rest of your life?
Yeah.
Cool.
Right?
Not too many hands going up there.
So you would all agree being very low and hydration as a problem,
right?
And you've heard this a thousand times,
Rick,
more water's better for you,
right?
Do you all realize that if you drink enough water that will kill you?
Okay?
Like you,
you all know this,
right?
There's a toxicity curve with water.
The most inner thing on the planet
has it.
Toxicity curve.
If you drink too much of it,
you get what's called hyponatremia.
Alright?
The,
the sodium potassium pumps.
The things are the reasons why you have an electrical gradient between the
muscles that cause contraction becomes diluted.
Nothing pumps the heart stops pumping,
right?
There's a toxicity curve to water.
Hmm.
I'll use an easier one.
How many of you are willing to go 15 minutes without oxygen?
Yeah.
Is that what you also do?
You also realize oxygen is probably the most toxic thing in the plant.
Like this is rust,
right?
This is a oxidize.
This is the problem here.
So vitamin C is no different.
Pick your mineral.
Um,
iron is a big one in men.
Sometimes men have too much iron.
Women have the same problem.
If you just give people prophylactic iron,
especially women,
this is a common new Lucy because the menstrual cycle,
we'll just give women more iron will fantastic.
That causes all kinds of oxidative problems.
It causes all kinds of damage.
DNA,
there's a ton of issues with that if you're giving them too much.
So you can't just give people things.
There's,
this is what I said a minute ago.
There are no free passes and physiology.
Nothing is good.
Nothing you'd look,
you have to stop thinking about molecules and personifying them.
Like there's no little evil body and a water molecule is like,
yes,
let me get the human.
Yeah,
I will get it right.
I just want to help people write that.
Yeah.
Movie inside,
inside out or whatever it was.
Yeah.
But yeah,
the molecules are not people.
A piece of water doesn't give,
um,
almost set a different word.
It doesn't care if you're happy or sad or anything like that.
Vitamin C is not toxic for you.
Uh,
you pick the worst,
most toxic thing in the planet.
It doesn't have a personality.
It doesn't care if it's sugar.
Yes.
Sugar like sugar doesn't hate you.
None of these things.
It's always about hormesis wears it on the curve.
And the crazy thing is pick any of these vitamins,
minerals,
or any,
uh,
pharmacologically developed item at some point.
It could save your life.
It could be the thing that changes how you feel.
It could also be the Senate thing that kills you or makes you feel worse,
right?
If you go further,
if it kills you.
So this is what I mean with all,
all those things you have to understand where you're at in that curve.
And a large part of it is you can get blood work done.
But that's very crude measure really.
It's about understanding how you feel because your body will tell you things and
it turns out nature's figured out a lot of this form yet how hermetic curve
pretty well
the amount of minerals,
for example,
vitamin C that you can get through nature are generally fine.
Hardly any of you are likely to be at a pass the hermetic curve where you're
going to have physiological problems by consuming too many oranges.
You're not going to get that much vitamin C because there's not that much
vitamin C in the orange.
Right?
It has a dosage that says this is probably going to be appropriate.
Well,
you can get into a problem though,
is taking things at dosages that are way higher than that than normal and in
nature,
so super concentrated,
exogenous things like a pill.
Right now you can get grams of vitamin C at a time.
This is something you would have never gotten in the natural world and you have
to be careful here of not making the natural fallacy.
Right,
which is it?
Just things just because things are this way in nature,
that means it's good that that's not true,
but it is fairly reasonable in this context is saved that the sugar would be the
same thing and we can certainly dive into that.
It's not the fact that there's too much sugar and a carrot,
right?
It's the fact that the way that people often consume sugar now it's in extremely
concentrated forms that would have not,
you would've had eat four bundles of carrots to get that much sugar or a beat
for that,
for that matter too.
So that's really the issue with all those things is we're not consuming those
things are we are consuming those things in concentrations or dosages that,
that our physiology is not really prepared for it.
So then,
um,
to bring him back here,
back to the local level,
then how can we take that information and apply it to like our day to day here
at Google?
Um,
is it like,
is there like a best practice?
You just like adjust your eating based on what the bacteria is out there is a
best practice and it's all laid out right here.
Nice.
Just kidding.
I'm not really,
but that's,
that's really what I'm talking about.
The,
the,
the best practice number one is to treat the problem,
not the symptom.
That's the issue.
So for example,
if we'll just keep writing vitamin C so you brought it up.
Why do people generally take vitamin C prophylactically?
Uh,
they feel sick.
They're about to get sick.
Perfect,
right?
If you're taking that all the time,
because every two or three weeks you feel like you're getting sick or you are
getting sick,
that will cover up the symptom may even fix it.
But what's the problem?
Something in your lifestyle or diet,
nutrition or sleep is wrong.
That's why you keep getting sick.
So you need to fix that problem.
Now you can take the vitamin C once or twice or something.
When you've got a crazy month and you've got to get this project or your over,
all right?
Fine.
But you have to realize that is the symptom that your body is trying to tell you
you're doing something wrong.
So some point you have to got to go back and fix the problem,
right?
And that could be a whole bunch of things.
It's terribly boring,
but I generally will apply the same problem or the solution for that problem to
everyone.
You're probably not sleeping well and consistently you're probably not eating
enough high quality food.
You're probably eating too much low quality things.
And you're probably not getting enough physical exercise,
like most boring talk ever.
Right?
It turns out it's really,
really true.
That's why we say it,
right?
Cliches are there for a reason.
What stereotypes are there for a reason?
They're generally pretty true.
Most of the time I got the chair over there.
They're pretty accurate at the general,
very general love,
right?
But that's what they're there for though.
We're trying to generalize.
We're trying to give big,
sweeping recommendations for everybody and it turns out those are the sweeping
recommendations that work really well.
So we'll get into this concept right now.
I guess.
I think the easiest way I can explain this is you on two ends here.
Over here you have optimization and this is something actually very applicable
to all of you.
And over here is adaptation.
So one of the things you have to realize about physiology,
when you're optimizing,
you're not adapting all right?
Or you can think of it as your super adapting.
So if you're walking around at all times optimizing,
you're actually causing the system to be more reliant upon that optimization.
I'll give you an example.
The easy one I can pick on here is caffeine.
So how many of you out there are willing to,
we're in the trust circle here.
Don't worry,
I'm only judging everything you're doing right now.
How many of you are willing to acknowledge that,
um,
your a daily consumer of caffeine.
I like to party,
I like to party virtually every hand goes up,
right?
How many of you think your day is significantly enhanced or improved by that
caffeine?
How many of you will keep going one step further?
Are actually willing to admit that if you were to not get that caffeine dose in
the morning,
your productivity or some other function you see as positive would would be
compromised,
right?
So what happens with caffeine over time to your ability for its effectiveness
over time diminishes?
So you're optimizing by taking that cap and I'm not against caffeine.
I'm going to go against us entirely in a second.
I just picked this one because it's a very easy one that I knew all.
All your hands would go up,
right?
I like,
I get it.
I'm a full time scientist.
I run laboratories.
I teach four classes semester.
I write books.
I do things like this.
I don't have any time either,
right?
I work with athletes.
We're all in that same time crunch.
I truly believe most people work about equally hard,
right?
None of have any free time,
so you're constantly optimizing.
You're doing what makes you feel the best right now because you've got to get
this thing done,
but then what happens it another project comes up and then another project comes
and you end up in this constantly optimizing everything,
right?
I'm taking my new tropic,
I'm taking my other vitamin C pills.
I don't get sick,
right?
I won't fix the lifestyle stuff.
I'll optimize everything right now.
I'll take all the caffeine I can to get through this project,
right?
But then I need more and more and more and then eventually what happens?
Boom.
You blow it a pieces,
right?
Physiology shuts down because it became so reliant on the technology.
What happens if you stop taking that caffeine
headache,
withdraw symptoms,
right?
All of these problems happen and you're like,
oh my gosh,
I can't stop taking the caffeine because you chose optimization.
Is that the same thing with diet?
Like like uh,
if I were,
you know,
to be 100% Quito and then I couldn't get that type of food and had to switch to
something else,
it would there be a similar reaction is similar idea.
But yeah,
you've become,
well we would say is non resilient,
right?
You don't want to put yourself in a position where you can't handle things.
You want to have some grit.
So I actually think it's great when people say,
hey look,
I know if I do these four or five things in the morning,
I become extremely clear and productive.
That's good.
I want you all to know those things.
I just don't want you to choose those every single time.
So in the book we talk about you have to engineer and manufacture suffering.
Sometimes you have to choose the hard path sometimes and you do that so that
this doesn't get slid too far to the right because then you end up optimizing so
much that optimal doesn't work anymore.
You've got to optimize more and it got optimize more and now we're no longer
having an effect.
And what do you think's happening to the physiology?
If you have to have caffeine to wake up in the morning,
what do you think happens to those indogenous processes that are there to help
you wake up?
They become dull,
right?
The sensitized.
They go away and eventually years later,
months later,
weeks later for whatever happens to me,
this becomes a problem.
And so the answer to your question,
what's the actionable step?
What can we do here at Google is,
yeah,
sometimes have caffeine or how of whatever you're looking for.
Again,
a caffeine,
it's just the one to pick on,
but then sometimes say,
you know what?
I'm going to perform today.
I'm going to execute.
I'm going to be focused today.
Without that stuff,
help the body learn to go back the other direction too so that it learns to do
that.
So you don't have to have those things.
You don't have to have 250 grams of fat a day just to not feel foggy headed.
If that's a problem,
you should learn to build in what's called metabolic flexibility.
All right,
so I'll grant you.
Some people are probably very dominant on carbohydrate,
overly dominant,
but that doesn't mean you should become overly dominant fat Bernie either.
That says the same thing,
but at the end,
the spectrum I want people to be able to do,
but both go back and forth.
So if you're in a situation where a lot of carbohydrates are available,
you can consume them or you want to for a thousand he said,
just want to have some carbohydrates.
I want you to have the physiology to go through that and not blow up the next
day or eight days later or fall asleep or whatever other silliness people say
it.
Right?
Same thing with fat.
I want you to also not have to go through your day without having to have
carbohydrate.
I think that is also equally a problem.
I don't think that it's very clear this is an issue,
right?
So your gut health,
your brain function,
your energy level should all have the resiliency to handle multiple different
stimuli.
This is where we are going to be optimal.
And the more time you can say pushing away from optimization,
spending an adaptation,
the more things get better.
You don't need to do those things as much.
All right,
so again,
I'm not saying,
all right,
let's throw away all the worst things is go back to just living on water and,
and Broccoli and,
no,
I'm just saying sometimes choose suffering,
sometimes choose optimization.
And if you can just think yourself and go,
boy,
you know what?
I haven't chilled suffering in a long time,
but then that's probably time to shoot some suffering.
I Dunno if that's weekly,
monthly,
I don't know what it is.
It doesn't matter.
But just having that,
and this actually where the last word in the book is consciousness.
Just having that awareness to go,
oh yeah,
all right,
and maybe it's time that I sleep for 10 hours for five straight days.
Right.
It's really interesting what people will choose to suffer with.
Some people will choose to suffer through exercise,
but they won't suffer through any hunger or they won't suffer through eating
something.
They don't.
I don't like that.
Like what?
You ran 20 miles yesterday,
but you won't eat something because you don't like the taste of it the last five
seconds.
That's the craziest thing.
Some people will work and sleep five hours a night for weeks on end.
Hmm.
But they won't do the opposite in the spectrum,
which is okay,
choose five days in a row where you sleep for 10 hours.
They won't choose that type of suffering because they don't like it.
The board,
or I'm agitated and I can't get,
I can't sleep at night,
so I'm going to pull my phone and go.
I'm like,
no,
no.
Put that away.
That's your suffering is not checking your phone every two seconds.
Whatever you're suffering happens to be.
Pick something that's hard.
I just make sure and,
and I use these examples that caffeine,
but I want really the goal of the book and the goal right here today is to help
you think about other aspects of your life.
Maybe that's paying attention to your wife more,
right?
Maybe that's not reacting to somebody in traffic as much.
Choose the optimization.
Choose what feels good.
Choose what gets you fixed the fastest right now,
but then sometimes choose what's going to be the longterm solution.
And it's the same thing I talked about.
This is fixing the problem.
First thing in the symptom.
The symptom is I woke up today exhausted,
I got to get as much as stuff done.
The symptom is fatigue,
but the problem was lifestyle.
The problem is lifestyle.
So balance those two things.
Yeah.
So they have noticed the line and um,
this might come up a couple a couple of times before,
but it's,
I feel that our peer group,
especially here,
you're not Google,
we're all,
you know,
around the same age.
We do similar activities,
but we're trying to optimize for too many things.
You know,
like,
uh,
like in my own personal case,
like,
you know,
I try to be ketogenic and also do Jujitsu and you know,
halfway through a role,
I mean,
you practice the sport as well and like help it to the wrong.
Just like,
yeah,
I'm not going for that triangle.
I'm dead man.
Like I'm like,
I can't get anything else.
And so I had to switch back to like,
okay,
like let's get more carbs and you go,
let's get you a little bit more ready in full so that when you're rolling,
like those colors are activated and you have that energy.
But like I couldn't do both at the same time.
And so I had to pick one or the other.
Yeah.
And that's a very good example when you try to make changes.
So sometimes you have to be realistic with expectations.
Right?
Now sometimes it's pretty much all.
And that particular case,
you had to understand what the true goal is.
Are you trying to get to Jitsu,
veterans,
Jujitsu right now?
Are you trying to get Keto adaptive?
I,
because sometimes those things are going to be antithetical,
right?
You have to understand if you don't make that decision of what the true goal is,
a right,
you'll never do the get to that change.
Because when things get hard,
you're gonna start making the change and your decision.
Right?
So the goal has to be,
I'm going to get keto adapted.
That means if you're wanting to,
yeah,
I will stay in with Quito and if that means you did some stuff for us right now,
fine,
I have to do that because I have to recognize the gold is over here.
Or if the goal is to be getting better at Jiu Jitsu for that week,
month block,
whatever happens to me,
this is a strength conditioning programming one on one,
right?
Right.
Have a goal for the day,
week,
month,
quarter,
year and then understand,
be true to that goal.
So when things start going wrong,
you look back up the chain and go,
yeah,
well the goal of this week was this and the goal this month was that therefore
here's my decision and I understand what to optimize for and what to push
towards adaptation.
So that,
that,
um,
that ability to,
to be,
to change your eating style.
So would that also apply to like working out?
Like,
is there a variability in straight the conditioning to that?
You would recommend 100% there should be very,
the ability with all of these things,
you should look at your lifestyle,
whether that's you're tricking,
your nutrition,
your exercise programming stuff,
and think,
when's the last time I did something different?
You should think globally,
right?
So how many of you think it'd be good to do the same workout every day the rest
of your life?
I got eye rolls there,
right?
Of course that doesn't make any sense.
Then why do you think there's one eating style you should do the rest of your
life?
That doesn't make any sense either,
right?
So you shouldn't just be keyed all the rest of your life.
You shouldn't be carbon heavy the rest of your life.
You shouldn't do any of these things the rest of your life.
You can't if you want,
but there's no real reason that you should hate one.
There's one way to eat ever,
but yet there's a thousand ways exercise.
It doesn't make any sense,
right?
If you start going back up the logic train,
you start thinking,
what am I trying to do with the exercise,
right?
And you have many,
many of us have different goals including things like I'm trying to get
healthier,
I'm trying to lose weight.
Right?
All right,
I want more energy.
And when you think about what the goal is,
that actually determines the outcome as opposed to working backwards,
which is to say,
I'm going to do this,
this program.
Why?
Because my friend did it and loved it.
That goes back to we said earlier,
well your friend might have been doing it for a different reason or it's super
popular for a different reason.
You have to think about what are you trying to get at it?
And this is,
I won't do this one right now because I'm sure none of you want to beat us
honest,
but it generally,
you've I'm sure heard the rule of three wise Wy why,
right?
It's three to five.
But when you,
when somebody comes at you with a problem in the terms of nutrition or diet and
you say,
I want to get x,
y,
why do you care about that?
Why do you care about that?
Why do you assume if you did this,
it would do that?
And that's always what it comes down to.
There's almost always a broken assumption.
Why are you assuming if you eat less carbohydrates,
you're going to lose more fat?
Well,
it just makes sense.
That's it.
You're gonna Change your whole lifestyle because of that.
Oh,
well what do you really want to do?
I really just wanna lose fat.
Great.
So if I give you a plan to lose fat,
would you be happy?
Yes or no?
Yes.
And if he lost the fact,
would you be happiest or no?
Yes,
I would be great.
Well then I'm going to use whatever tool I can to help you lose fat.
You brought a solution,
you brought an option there,
which is a fine option.
But I'm going to look at the rest of the things and say,
that's not going to work in your lifestyle.
I know you got kids,
I know you've got this thing going on.
This is not,
this is not very unlikely to succeed for you.
So can I offer you another option that I think is more likely to succeed that
we'll get to that goal.
That's what I'm after.
That's what we're always doing.
So with exercises,
the same thing.
What are we trying to do here?
And I'm trying to,
well my mom had a osteoporosis so I don't,
I want to make sure I don't have that.
Oh,
okay.
Or my dad just had a heart attack and so I'm really thinking about longterm
health or hey look,
it's summertime.
It's Venice.
I need to get ready for the pop this shirt off.
Fine.
Like whatever happens to be,
let's get to the honest answer.
And people are shocked cause I don't care.
I actually don't think vanity is the worst thing ever here.
If that drives you to exercise more.
Okay.
That that can be a problem.
At the end of the horn is Curtis.
It's like anything else,
right?
But for a lot of people find if that's what it takes,
well then let's talk about that.
And now we're going to work backwards to figure out what program or style of
training you need to do to get that goal as opposed to just picking a style of
training.
Like that doesn't make any sense at all.
And then of course when the goal changes,
now we're going to rotate training philosophies based on what the next goal is.
And so speaking of training and like genetics,
like how much of what you have is like fixed,
like assuming again that I'd become,
you know,
you know the best Mexican American UFC fighter ever.
Um,
you know,
how much of that is limited by what I already have or did that complete change
my bill or am I kind of just stuck as is.
So we've actually ran a recent trial with some his leg as twins.
So these are twins.
They had the exact same DNA,
so they're clones and one of them had stopped exercising when he was about 18 or
20 years old.
And the other one I continued to exercise and at the time when we tested them,
they're in their early fifties,
so really 30 years of different exercise training and well,
everything that you in your body is slightly different here.
Uh,
generally at worst you're talking about 50,
50 genetics and lifestyle.
Some of the markers more aggressive.
Some of the things that we saw were closer to 80,
20 in favor of lifestyle,
really not genetics.
Uh,
the exposome is what some people refer to this I think,
not genetic.
So it depends on what you're talking about.
If you're talking about something like how tall you are,
that's pretty much 100% genetic,
right?
There's not a lot we can do.
Sorry,
sorry man.
But if you look at something like,
uh,
your overall health or I'll,
I'll pick a maybe more specific example.
We took muscle biopsies and we analyze them for fiber type,
right?
So most of you heard there's fast twitch muscle fibers is low to a tray.
Well,
unlike what most people think,
there's tremendous plasticity within that.
So you can swing back,
you can go from fast to slow,
slow to fast really quickly.
We've seen changes in fiber type in the disorders,
two weeks,
uh,
11 days really.
And in this particular case,
one of the twins was about 50,
50,
fast twitch and slow twitch and the other one was about 90% slow twitch.
So I really,
basically for things like again,
height,
you can't really change.
But anything that has any plasticity to it,
there really is no limit to how much it changes.
It only comes down to exposure.
So the more often you do it,
the longer you have to do it.
For example,
if I took these twins and I had another 100 years to keep them going,
they would continue to change.
It's not a physiological limit,
it's just the limit to exposure,
time and load,
right?
And so you have unlimited ability to change virtually anything about you if you
give it enough exposure.
So that means you have to be patient and you have to do things often.
If you're consistent,
you do it often and you wait time Bateson basically anything about your body,
your physique and especially things like muscle,
it had virtually no limit to plasticity w within our lifestyle or within our
lifetime at this stage.
So everything really can change.
Got It.
And how,
how related is that to like the idea of epigenetics that some fake turn off and
on depending on what you do is that there's this,
go back to the 20 example you just shared.
Yeah,
that is one example of that.
So you have genes that you can't change.
You can't change the DNA that you've inherited.
Uh,
but we've been doing this for decades now.
The idea that just because you have a gene doesn't mean that gene is going to be
expressed if that gene is not expressed,
no proteins are built,
nothing happens.
So somebody that say that gets a bad drop because certainly people get better
draws genetically and some get worse.
So for let's say,
Oh,
give me an example myself.
Um,
I've done a bunch of genetic testing and I have a lot of markers for obesity.
And so if you calculate the rough numbers,
I have something like 15 or 16 x,
the risk of obesity,
and I'm not the best looking person you've ever seen with their shirt off over
there and the beach,
but it's not too bad.
Right?
Everyone else in my family is obese.
Everyone,
for most part,
I have the same.
I have very bad genetics when it comes to those things.
I have to work very hard in my exercise and nutrition.
It's not just natural.
I wasn't born with a fast metabolism.
That's all garbage.
Right?
I have the genetic markers that gave me every excuse to be obese,
but if I don't match that with the lifestyle,
those genes are never going to really matter that much.
If though I gave my lifestyle a little bit,
it would take off.
Some people get a lot,
some people even have much higher on the the obesity thing than I,
and they matched that.
Did they pretty well,
their lifestyle's pretty good,
but that's enough to really send them off the edge.
Right.
And so they have to work really hard and do everything to just kinda stay there.
Some people are on the other end of that spectrum.
It doesn't really matter what they do.
They're not going to be in the surface level obese.
But keep in mind a major misnomer here is skinny,
is not healthy and obese is not unhealthy necessarily either.
Adding more fat mass is generally never a good thing for your health.
But just because you're not fat does not mean you're healthy.
And we have tremendous data on this.
Uh,
hundreds of thousands of people now in dozens of studies across laboratories
across the world.
Some of the most significant predictors of mortality,
so this is when you're going to die,
are things like leg strength.
It's not obesity,
it's things like vo two Max.
It's not your cholesterol.
So you could be somebody who is quote unquote skinny,
have weak legs,
have a low vo two Max and be at two to three times if not higher.
The mortality risk of somebody who's a little bit overweight,
but they have a reasonable vo two Max and a reasonable like strength because
they're acting like if you want to talk about health,
that's what health means.
So really depends on are you talking about aesthetics or health?
But those are different conversations.
Just because you're not fat as does not mean you're healthy.
You could be right above that line of dime.
Got It.
And so speaking of lifestyle,
you have this wonderful now that you either what you described,
the differences and in terms of eating in between a cook,
oh yeah.
Baker and a chef.
Uh,
I would love for you to,
to share a little bit about that.
So like any analogy,
it's not perfect,
right?
But what I try to do is,
as I mentioned,
it's a little bit of blended.
The soft sciences and the hard sciences.
I'm a hard scientist,
right?
It's quantitative versus qualitative.
Everything in my world is quantitative biopsy.
You measure everything,
molecules.
We measured signaling proteins,
genes,
things like that.
And there's no fudging,
there's no look,
look,
you look pretty good that that doesn't work in muscle physiology.
But the soft sciences are more qualitative.
Right?
And so what I try to do is when I'm speaking to a client,
an athlete,
or even a student,
or even my parents,
are you right now,
there's two conversations that go on in my head.
The conversation number one is what's the information?
What's the thing I'm trying to say?
Conversation number two is what's the best way I need to say it to you
to have the impact,
right?
If I give you every piece of information I know in my head you can't execute,
and it oftentimes that confuses you even more and makes you go,
I'm out.
Like I just wanted one answer.
I would've started taking vitamin C.
DO I do it?
Yes or no?
I'm out.
So you have to have two conversations going to translate what I think I need to
say to you.
So my analogy that I make up with the Cook Baker and chef is my way of putting
people in personality categories for one simple metric,
which is nutrition.
And that helps me understand how I need to communicate with them.
And it actually works really well because people fall into this cook Baker chef
analogy in every aspect of their life.
But you may switch back.
So when you go to work here in a second,
you might be a baker,
but then with your own nutrition,
you might be a cook.
So people aren't just a cook or a baker in all aspects of life.
It changes depending on the rules.
So for example,
for me,
and I'll get into what this cook Baker chef thing is a second for nutrition,
I am definitely,
I cook,
but when it comes to my taxes,
not like not the same way,
right?
When it comes to fixing my car,
I'm totally a baker,
right?
I'm,
I'm following every instruction.
I'm not,
I can feel here,
right?
This might go here.
It's just put that there.
Right.
And so these analogy is,
do any of you know the difference between cooking and baking?
I started just gave you a hint.
Baking is chemistry,
right?
Baking is extremely precise.
You cannot do things in different orders.
When you bake,
you can't be like,
well,
I'll just get the baking powder outs.
Tossa men like not going to work.
Like was that baking soda or baking powder?
I camera.
Just throw one of them in.
All right.
Put a little bit both not going to work on chemistry,
right?
So the Yolo move,
just put in both.
See what happens.
Yeah,
exactly.
Right.
Generational millennials.
It's what you do cooking.
Is that though,
right?
Cooking as well.
Okay.
Yeah.
You just kind of get it hot.
Put it in the pan.
Uh,
put a little bit of this,
a little bit of that in there.
Well,
it doesn't really matter if you have it and you know not what?
Chaotic,
that's it.
Not going to kill it.
It just kind of toss things around.
Right?
So people process information the same way.
How many of you,
if I said,
look for having me up here today,
I'm going to actually go ahead and you offer you my services for free for the
next 30 days.
I'll be your personal nutritionist next 30 days.
No charge.
Uh,
how many of you have,
I said,
look,
I will write you a specific program.
I'll tell you exactly what to eat,
when to eat.
You have to weigh,
you have to buy a little scale,
you have to wait.
Every single thing you eat,
you have to report it back to me.
And if you fail one meal,
I'm out.
How many of you would love something like that?
Right?
Huh?
How many of you were like,
what if I just,
we met like once a week for 30 minutes or an hour.
You could ask him a couple of questions.
I gave you some concepts and then you went back.
How many of you would like that?
Right?
You are a baker,
your cooks.
If if we worked together and now especially if you paid me,
if you're paying me $1,000 a to do this and you wanted that kind of information
at that level of detail and all I gave you was,
well you don't just a little more protein,
the cubic pissed,
right?
You're like you'd be freaking out.
Like what's the great example I give all the time,
times my wife,
cause she is a bake when it comes to food.
So when I first started helping her years ago with an nutrition,
you know,
I'd be like,
okay,
this is a little bit of,
um,
little bit of a woman's walnuts today at lunch.
She'd be like,
well,
well what do you mean like like eight almonds or walnuts 11.
What are we talking about?
Cause she came,
she's a baker it plus she came from that counting calorie thing.
She came from all this and she wants,
she gave her anxiety to not have that information.
You,
if I gave you all that information,
he would give you anxiety because you're like,
oh my God,
it's controlling my life.
It's too much.
So even though the answer to all of your nutritional problems,
we'll just say is the exact same thing.
I cannot communicate to you how I communicate to the rest of you.
It's going to be ineffective.
So I have to have that second conversation with says,
okay,
how does she want to hear this information and what do I need to tell her?
I can't give her too much.
I can't give her too little.
There's a thing called Buyin,
right?
You got to be convinced and excited it's going to work.
It's gotta be overload.
And I got to make sure that I'm trying to line you up with buyin as well as
feeling good about,
yeah,
no,
I see why you gave me wellness because this was going on and they see why you
added this because we are here.
Perfect.
That's going to fix my problems.
You might not care about that.
You're like,
look,
I just wanna be a little bit less fat.
Give me some ideas.
What am I doing wrong?
Cool.
And you were really empowered by that.
You're excited by that versus added anxiety to your plan.
Right?
So bakers need to be given very specific instructions.
Even here's the secret.
Even if those instructions aren't perfectly right,
it doesn't really matter.
I don't know if you need to be on 180 grams of carbohydrate or 280 but if I told
you that you wouldn't be happy.
But if I walked down like,
Oh yeah,
no,
you need to be at one 75 exactly.
Don't go to one 90 be at one 75 you went,
oh sweet,
great.
And I turned around.
You would rather hear that the not hear that because you have a plan.
Some of you are planners,
right?
Some of you liked that.
The detail,
and we can adjust the plan as we go.
So you can a week come back to me and go,
look,
I'm feeling boom,
boom,
boom.
Oh,
okay,
let's take those carbs.
Let's go up to two 20 and see what happens.
Okay,
great.
You just like having a plan,
right?
Some of you don't want,
that's too much.
You can take over your life,
you're not going to execute it.
And the number one thing with diet nutrition,
the number one thing to actually changing something is adherence.
If nobody does the plan,
then there is no plan.
So my cook,
Baker,
chef thing is trying to help people put them in a position where they actually
might execute the plan.
So give them something they're going to be excited about.
That doesn't give too much anxiety.
Now what's a chef?
Is a chef following recipes or not?
Not really.
Why can a chef not follow recipes?
Because they followed the recipe exactly for so many years.
They have an advanced degree in that and now they understand when to break those
rules.
They understand the consequences,
they understand how things are working to a level they can innovate.
They can do things differently because they know,
okay well I'm going to do less of that.
What I got to do this on the backend.
Oh Cook doesn't have that experience or knowledge.
They didn't put in the groundwork the years of working to understand,
no,
you can't just throw the oil end.
Yeah it's going to blow up and you know,
spot splatter huddle over your face.
All right,
but the chef probably did that a bunch of times.
That's what I learned that those lessons and now they can break rules cause they
understand,
well you can do this as a,
you can't do that,
but you can break that,
that,
that and then that.
Right.
So a chef is somebody that understand those rules to a such a level.
I can go boom and I can weave back and forth between communicating like a baker
or a cook with them and and I'm,
I'm confident they won't break those fundamental rules that I didn't want them
to break.
Or my ideal goal of course,
is to work everyone up to being a chef to where I can go.
So it's me when you need me,
right?
With any of these things I'm trying to,
and this is really a big part of the book,
I'm trying to push people away from becoming self dependent.
It's becoming self reliant.
If you have to follow a textbook or an app to eat every day,
you're becoming dependent on that,
right?
That's not what we want you to be.
Wanting to be self reliant where you can go,
okay,
this was a great starting place.
This helped me learn my body more.
This diet that I followed,
I followed it to a tee.
I didn't make any variations in it.
I learned a lot more about what I react well to them.
I don't rap to look great.
Now I'm going to ditch the book.
That's the plan.
It's the magic thing
and start changing things on my own.
Oh No.
Understanding of what that triggered me really fast.
Oh my gosh.
Now I'm feeling super tired.
I'm nodding off after lunch.
Okay.
It's because I added this.
I can't do that.
I gotta make this combination different.
Right?
And so it should be used to help you advance,
not regress you back to,
oh,
I don't have my book,
my app crashed,
my phone died.
Oh my God,
I don't know what to eat for lunch.
Okay.
That's what happens.
Right?
When we don't want you to be at that level.
So you don't want to give people,
when you give people very specific answers,
they become reliant upon those answers and they don't become,
or they become dependent upon those answers.
They don't become self reliant.
And that's really where we're trying to get people to get there because anyone
who's ever had a significant change in their health function or performance is a
lifestyle change.
And that's where we're always trying to get people to get to,
right?
If you make them dependent upon external forces information.
If you make them be a permit baker,
they'll never going to become a chef.
But if you're always a cook as well,
you'll never know what to do to become a chef either.
So there's a little bit of both.
We have to go back to this.
So that's generally what I do.
So when I'm working with an athlete in my head,
I go,
okay,
all right Steve,
right?
He's a baker.
I'm filtering everything through.
Bakers do well with a bunch of instructions,
very specific detail,
cooks,
shore piece of information and they don't care why,
right?
So four,
we'll go back there again.
We're,
I'm working with you all as a nutritionist,
if I gave you is I said,
hey,
I want you to take 11 wall nuts going to eat those at 11:00 AM 11 not 12 you'd
probably go,
cool,
great.
I'm in.
But why
you wouldn't give a shit?
I'm like,
sweet,
I'm on it.
Let me go 11 here we are.
We're done.
Cooks don't care about the why.
Baker's tend to care about the why.
So the baker,
I spend more time with the buying of explaining to them how it's going to work.
Well,
it's because we saw this in your blood panel and we saw this in your school
sample.
We're doing this.
Okay,
great.
Bakers or cooks just one or the answer.
Great question.
Yeah,
I'm in,
I'm out.
Come back in a month,
let me know if it didn't work right.
And so it's just trying to help improve communication.
And my decade is a teacher has helped me build that.
So although I'm a hard scientist,
I'm a qualitative or quantitative scientist by nature,
I'm also,
I spend a lot of time teaching and so really I developed that as a tool with
both my students and my athletes is a way of saying,
okay,
how can I change my system so that I can improve for them?
I'm trying,
I'm not trying to make all of my athletes,
chefs or all my students,
some don't want to be.
Some of you might realize like,
look,
it's your show is not my jam.
I want to be healthier,
but I'm not,
I'm not going to dive into it.
I'm not gonna start reading stuff like,
okay,
great.
I'm not going to try to make that person a chef.
All right.
Yeah,
I don't,
I don't want you to work how I work.
I want you to work how you work.
You tell me how you work and I will change to help you.
That's my job.
When you hire me and pay me to help you do something,
I'm not trying to push you into my system.
I'm trying to change to fit you and give a system to whatever you want.
That's what I'm really trying to do.
It
no nice.
That's,
I mean,
if that's a great approach to everything and you know,
the more that we can adapt to our audience,
whether it's in the workplace and nutritional space,
then uh,
the more impactful the message will be.
Right.
That's cool.
Nice.
So I'm at this point,
I'd love to open it up to questions.
Um,
all right.
Oh,
shocking.
All right.
Has a question.
So Your Rita?
Yup.
Alright.
We practiced this before,
so you've got this,
I'm ready.
Oh my gosh.
What are we doing here?
Yes,
it's googleable that was pretty athletic.
Yeah.
Well I do work out.
Ah,
ah,
thanks very much for coming.
And I've found the talk very interesting.
Um,
one of the things I think is most interesting is how much you've talked about
nutrition and how it's extremely subjective.
I mean,
yes you can call me a baker,
but for nine years I was vegetarian,
seven years of that I was Vegan and that was kind of by accident,
but it was also kind of because I was told by a bunch of friends that it was
better for my health.
I read some books on it,
they all said it was better for me.
Um,
and then I developed hypoglycemia.
Yup.
And really bad acid reflux,
which I didn't know was caused by that.
Um,
I went back to eating gradually everything and 10 years later still was
hypoglycemic,
still having problems with the acid reflux.
So,
um,
I read the blood type diet book.
Okay.
I'm sure you're familiar with it.
Yeah,
sure.
Um,
and it's like,
not very scientific,
but you know,
I was like willing to give it a try.
I'm a baker.
So I followed the,
the,
the recipes or you know,
the instructions.
And within two months my hypoglycemia was gone.
Awesome.
Within three months,
acid reflux all gone.
And now I don't follow it religiously because I,
I,
I've actually graduated to being a chef.
I don't like to brag,
but it's totally fine.
But I did experiment with all this stuff.
And,
and what I've told people,
especially people that,
um,
that we know that are like really hardcore vegetarians and vegans is that it's
not for everyone.
No.
And it really is a personal choice and,
and it's not about the s saving the planet is great and,
and saving the animals is great and saving the environment is great.
There's other ways I can do that.
Yup.
Um,
that are not going to affect how I feel every day.
And um,
I was just wondering what kind of advice do you offer to people when they're,
so I'm attached to a diet,
which by the way is from the Greek.
It means way of life.
They're so attached to a diet that actually is hurting them and they refused for
like usually moral reasons like because of the animals,
they won't let go of it.
Sure.
Even though it's hurting them.
So a couple of things.
Number one,
the vegetarian Vegan argument,
you have to tease out ethics from health,
right?
Right.
Those are separate conversations.
You can't,
you can't believe back and forth.
So I'll leave the moral ethics stuff aside.
It's not what I do.
I can certainly comment on it.
This is not the best use of our short time here today.
The health thing is,
is the easier approach as you mentioned,
it would be extremely arrogant and shortsighted for us to think all seven,
seven and a half billion people have to eat the same way and that our health
would be optimized eating the same way.
It's undeniable.
Some people do fantastic on those sites.
Health wise.
It's also undeniable.
Some don't.
It's pretty silly also to think you have to eat like that to be healthy.
Go pick your evidence point evolution,
our biology,
current clinical,
uh,
randomized clinical trials.
None of it,
Matt.
None of it lines up,
right?
So any of that is a win and it's overwhelming.
It's just you can't ignore that or even really ethically debate that.
Right?
You can't genuinely debate that.
It's just silly.
The bigger problem I think that puts into,
we as humans have been around for a long time.
How
could you in a objective logical mind think we
were the generation that figured it out?
Like are you kidding?
What do you think the generation and what,
what do you think someone's going to do in 10 years from now?
No,
no.
They're the ones that figured out your life.
And so I think if you run the circle pattern enough,
you realize,
oh,
what's the answer?
What's the common thread between all of it?
There is no single best diet,
right?
That that's not going to exist.
It never will.
There is not a single best approach.
And again,
why do you think you even have to do one approach your whole life?
So why not go Vegan,
vegetarian for a year
and then go back and then something else?
Why not more?
Why does it have to be one answer or whole time?
Anyone that claims that a diet like that is these single answer for an entire
generation or entire population.
Maybe they have good intentions in mind,
but it's not the right approach at generally doesn't help people.
So the second part of your question,
how do you communicate with these people that are entrenched?
Number one,
you can't.
If people aren't ready to change,
they don't change.
Uh,
information always helps,
but it has to be genuine information.
So for example,
I could very easy easily stand up here and attack those diets from a science
perspective.
But I don't do that because it doesn't help anything.
People that like Vegan vegetarian are not going to be excited by that.
It's not going to help anybody.
People in the middle don't like it.
You can get a lot more views on youtube.
Like you could cut a little clip out there like Dr Galpin blast vegetarian and
Google talk.
I'm not interested in that crap.
It doesn't help the movement.
What helps us information,
right?
And,
and there's a ton of information out there and being genuinely compassionate and
empathetic for those people,
really trying to help them and when they're ready.
Uh,
again,
my approach is,
so when I,
I have worked with vegetarian,
Vegan athletes,
I have not once uttered any of them that we should change their diet with
exceptions of the one that has been like,
hmm,
I want to do this because I thought it's healthier that person as well.
Why?
Why did you think that?
Why do you think that,
okay,
great.
And if they have a very good reason,
I'm not against it,
I would go there.
I will use any tool that they want,
but I will never take a person that comes to me and says,
look,
I'm Vegan.
I want to be vegetarian but this,
and this is going on.
I want to improve my health,
but I want to stay vegetarian.
I would never start the conversation off about how to get them away from
vegetarian.
My goal is to help them succeed with what they're doing.
So that's my approach.
Once they do that,
they're probably more likely to understand you care about them and then they
might start opening up and being like,
well really what do you think about,
you think it is healthier this way?
And then I'll give her my honest opinion,
but I'm not going to walk in and start pushing when I have an athlete that comes
into with with Kido and it things,
my goal is not to push them away from any of that stuff.
I want to help them succeed with what they want to doing.
And if I walk them to see like where are you at?
Scale of one to 10 with a vegetarian veganism in terms of willing to give it up.
Not if they go nine,
great.
I'm not even going to subconsciously,
I'm not going to like hit little jabs at him.
I'm not even going to try.
That's not,
that's how they came here for.
They came to me because I want to get better with what they're at.
Fine.
Just like somebody that came to me with a carnivore diet or any other crazy
diet.
That's what you wanna do.
Great.
Okay.
Well,
I'll do my best to try to help you through that,
but I'm not going to try to change you unless you want to change.
Then all of a sudden I'll maybe help.
But that's not my goal.
I don't want to him when he's eating.
I don't want him to believe in my philosophies.
Um,
I'll try to help you as I can,
but that doesn't help anyone.
Nice.
Yeah.
Some you said there is no single solution for things.
Uh,
but also I,
well I have like knee condition or ankle condition.
I've realized that there was no,
even the x per say,
different things about how to treat my conditions.
And so you've been working with the best people,
uh,
in that area.
So,
uh,
can you give us a tip on how to find the good doctor or Neutropenia?
The nutrition is toward physic.
Yeah,
that's,
that's such a good question.
I get that probably more than anything else.
When I do media or in a classroom,
it's a,
it's something that I wish I had perfectly solved myself.
Right.
But I don't.
You can look for red flags though.
If anybody is selling a product directly behind themselves,
it's not,
it's not a bias.
It's not guaranteed wrong,
but if the answer to every single person that walks in our clinic is,
Oh yeah,
yeah,
you got to take this thing,
then you start to be like,
hm,
weird.
The other ones you want to pay attention to,
are they the ones that are treating symptoms?
Not Problem,
right?
You want them what?
Find the ones that address a problem in the last piece I'll say to that is you
want to find people that are treating the entire system,
not the knee,
because the knee is a symptom.
That's the signal,
but that may not be the cause of the problem.
I am,
I don't know what your knee issue is,
but it might be something that it might be because of your neck.
It might be because of your right shoulder and so you want to find a physician
that asks questions about everything.
They'll sit you down and go,
okay,
you have any problem talking about any problem?
Okay,
great.
Well,
let me see.
You walk.
Okay,
let's take this other thing.
Well,
tell me about your diet.
Tell me what,
when do you feel most symptoms?
When are you feeling it?
Flare Up.
What activities get her.
Okay,
great.
Well,
let's look at your posture.
Let's look at how you move.
How do you sleep?
What's your desk look like?
What's your car ride?
Are you commuting a lot?
And then we can be,
okay,
what's your stress?
How much are you sleeping?
That's,
that's somebody who will fix your problem.
So those are the people I look for.
If,
if you're,
if you're going to the position or the physical therapist and they go,
okay,
what's you need problem?
All the back of my knee hurts when I stand up too much.
Okay,
great.
Uh,
do three sets of 10 of this.
Like Garth walkout gone.
Like they're not fixing anything.
Or if they just went,
oh,
okay,
great.
Um,
start on these anti-inflammatories and we'll see what happens.
Not gonna work,
man,
like not going to work.
So keep walking out of those offices until you find somebody that really treats
the symptom.
And it's really hard.
Of course,
I could give you personal referrals to people,
but I don't want to sound like a plugging anybody specifically because there's
tons of people to do this.
Um,
you can look up,
um,
I make,
I didn't want to say this,
but to hell with it,
I'll just say it.
You can look up functional medicine now.
Some functional medicine practitioners are complete quacks,
but a lot of them tend to be decent and that's a good start because they tend to
treat the body.
It's a really bad buzz term right now.
Be Very careful with it.
There's a lot of hot and cold on functional medicine right now.
There's some bad stuff going on with that as well,
but some of that,
they at least are pushing the concept forward of treating the system.
I think one of the biggest miss services we've ever done in the field of health
and fitness is teaching people different body systems.
You learn the muscle system and you learn the bone system.
You learn the nervous system because that's not how that works.
And it makes people think siloed.
Oh,
I have a bone problem,
therefore fixed the bone.
Well,
it might be a nerve issue.
It might be a gut issue.
It might be as might be the fact that you don't sleep well.
It turns out when you sleep well,
all these things go away.
The body works in systems.
We have multiple things,
right?
So when you fix those big hanging fruit,
everything tends to start the lineup.
Uh,
so I would go to a physician or a therapist or whoever you're looking for that
asks all the questions about the lifestyle habits and that fixes your problem.
So a long answer,
but that's my real answer.
Thanks.
Oh,
minus 10.
So you talked a lot about like finding a balance within,
um,
the choices you make and making sure that you understand the consequences of
things to do.
I'm curious to understand how do you approach something like weight cutting?
Something that I'm like,
UFC fighters have to do,
like they just have to make a certain way.
Um,
yeah.
I'll give you a global answer and then maybe you can follow up with this
specific thing.
So,
I'm not sure exactly what you're asking so you can do a follow up here,
but it's like anything else during that extreme weight cut and we've,
we've been a part of some very extreme lens.
You're talking people,
I'm the closest one,
the biggest one I've ever been.
Even just peripherally a part of,
we had an APP that you go from 252 pounds down to 185 pounds,
right?
Really probably had 12 weeks for that or something.
Um,
I've seen people though within,
uh,
let's say on a Tuesday,
weigh ins are usually Friday.
Um,
you know,
go from one 78 to one 55.
Uh,
I've seen 20 pounds,
20 pounds cut in 24 hours or less.
Of course,
that's almost exclusively water,
right?
So the really way I manage that is you go through those periods,
and I can tell a story about this.
I worked with an athlete who won a gold medal in Rio Olympics and about four
months out,
two or three months out,
the weight just stopped coming off.
And that's because she had been in a state of low calorie for nine 10 12 months.
And we had to match that optimization with adaptations.
So what we did actually is we gave her a boatload of carbohydrate way up on
calories,
almost all from vegetable and weight.
Just started falling off.
Just started coming up because she had been so low calorie.
And what generally when low calorie you get low nutrient because you just don't
have quantity.
We had to go there other.
So it was like,
let's make the body feel better for a minute.
Let's give you a couple of weeks of feeling better.
And as soon as it did that,
it kind of relax if you will.
And then the fat started falling off and she got down midway,
no problem,
want to go metal.
He became the first American actually female ever to win gold medal and
wrestling.
So they're like,
this is a huge thing.
She upset,
uh,
16 times straight world champion I had to beat.
So we,
you have to match at the same way.
So when my athletes come,
I literally had a conversation this morning with one of mine.
When you come off that hard cut thing,
we have to match it with,
let's restore.
That's recover.
That's not ballooned up to two 50 again,
but let's match it there.
So that's I think,
but I'm not sure what you're really asking.
Good follow up now.
I mean,
those basic rules asking mood.
Um,
could you speak more specific to like,
um,
like how do you,
like after,
after the event,
after they started recovery,
like how do you do it in a way that's like,
so one key,
um,
[inaudible] had someone one time after a pretty big weight cut one,
a very big,
um,
competition.
She was extremely excited and had been in a very,
very clean diet for months.
And then she sent me a picture because she was on,
um,
I don't know,
one of those daytime talk shows or something.
One of the big news things afterwards.
And she sent me a picture,
like they brought me in and pizza and chocolate and all this stuff.
And I'm like,
do not eat that.
I'm like,
yes,
it's reward time,
but you're going to blow up like this is not.
Of course she ate it and very much regretted it.
We'll put it that way if you get what I'm saying.
Not that not what you want to be feeling when you're on national TV.
My point is it's just going back to the same thing.
We just start increasing calories,
but you can't just go off the rails.
I made this mistake one time after a personal,
uh,
weight cut of my own and I went to,
to um,
to a place that serves wings and beer.
It was like I have one beer and a bunch of wings and fries.
Oh my gosh.
The worst.
Right?
You feel awful.
And so you,
you,
oh,
you bring in counties and you can have a little bit of a treat,
but you have to work yourself back into that stuff as well.
And the,
the very detail,
it's the same food.
You just need a little more.
It's more vegetable,
more fresh fruit,
maybe a little bit more,
uh,
fat if you want,
but you're eating real whole foods.
Once you do that for a little bit,
then you can actually have the luxury to eat ice cream or cake or whatever
little indulgence wine like hers was wine.
Okay fine.
But you can't just go off the rails and just go back from really fresh,
clean foods for nine months to garbage,
you're going to get destroyed.
So that's really what we do.
It's just the same way we come back up.
And you have to be careful though because about two months later it was like,
yeah.
So you remember how you said I can add a little bit of chocolate now?
Yeah,
I'm pretty much eating chocolate every day,
all day.
I was like all right,
time to tighten back down like,
and come back the other way.
So it's just balancing those two things.
Awesome.
You guys.
Any more questions?
Perfect.
Well doctor Galpin has a pleasure.
Privilege.
Thanks so much for stopping by.
And uh,
yeah guys,
you got his book,
it's unplugged.
A few more copies right up here and yeah,
feel free to hang around.
Let's go get some state cause it's steak day.
So let's party.
Perfect.
Thanks for me.
Thanks for having me.
[inaudible].